PROFESSOR: So let's build
on this concept of diffusion
of virions in
droplets to understand
how we would expect a
size dependent infectivity
of virions in different
sized droplets.
So an important
concept in epidemiology
that we will come to
later is the infectivity,
which is the probability
that if a virion is transferred
that it actually causes
an infection in the host.
That can be further
broken down into a product
of two probabilities.
The first is that if the virus
has escaped from the droplet,
it actually causes an infection.
And that's perhaps something
which is roughly constant.
It has to do with the
physiology of the host.
But then there is the escape
of the virion from the droplet.
And as we've already
discussed, that's
a strongly size
dependent quantity.
And from very large
droplets, it's
very difficult in a mucus
droplet, especially,
for the virion to diffuse out
in a reasonable amount of time.
And in fact, virions
are typically
found to have a
period of deactivation
where after a certain
amount of time,
they are no longer viable
and able to basically cause
further infection.
And so if we assume
there's a certain time
t, or tau v for the
virus deactivation,
then we can ask
ourselves if the virus
has had a chance to escape
or not as a function of size.
So basically, to
solve this problem,
we think of the droplet here.
And we actually want to
solve a diffusion problem
where C here is the
concentration of viruses
in the domain.
D is the diffusivity
of the viruses.
And this is the
[INAUDIBLE] equation
in the sphere, which is
the diffusion equation.
And our boundary
conditions are that C of R
and 0, the initial
condition is 0.
And then at R and t,
it's going to be one.
So basically what
we're imagining here
is that we're
trying to figure out
the C will be the
concentration viruses that
has left the system actually.
So what we have is if we look
as a function of the radius,
of the radius of this
thing is R, capital R. So
in that distance, we
have this constant--
what I'm calling
concentration here is just
going to jump up to one.
And then it's going to
diffuse inward like this.
OK, and then eventually
the final state
is that it's entirely
basically one everywhere.
And that's when basically
the probability of removal
has hit every part of the
drop and all of the virus
has been removed.
So the C is a time
dependent fraction
of the virus, the virions
in the droplet, which
had been removed at time t.
So this spherical
diffusion equation
can be solved analytically
in various ways.
But there's not a simple closed
form solution to this problem.
And what we're really
interested in here
is just a rough
approximation of what
the solution might look like.
So let's pull out an
approximation for this.
So I'll sketch the
droplet again here.
Now at early times,
when there hasn't
been a chance for the
viruses, the virions
to diffuse very far.
Then only those which
are close to the boundary
actually have a
chance of leaving.
That's this initial boundary
earlier that I sketched here,
which is working its way in.
So why don't we
sketch the central region
and give that a distance delta,
which is the boundary layer
thickness.
So basically this outer
annulus has been--
is really where virions
had a chance to leave.
And that's where c
is jumping to one.
And from-- if this
were just a plane
with a semi-infinite diffusion
towards the center, so
in other words, this
delta is much less than R,
capital R, the radius, then
it's almost like diffusion
from a planar source.
And then we actually know
that this distance as well
approximated by
square root of 2 DT.
So that just comes from solving
the diffusion equation in one
dimension leads to that
scaling of the diffusion layer
thickness.
So that's this thickness
of this blue region
as it goes that way is delta.
And it scales as
it's approximated
by square root of 2DT.
And now let's ask
ourselves then what
is this concentration here?
Well, what I'm really
interested in actually
is this escape probability PE.
And that's going
to be the integral
of CDV over the volume.
So this is the integral
over all the R's that
are less than capital
R. So basically
inside the drop of this
concentration field.
So that contrary field starts
at 0 and eventually goes to 1.
And that base is giving me
this total escape probability.
So to calculate this integral
of the concertation field,
I basically have a
domain at the outside
here with the concept of
this concentration variable
is near one and a
central region where
it's C approximately zero.
And here C is equal to
one on the boundary.
This variable I've defined here.
So therefore, I can write that
this PE is, roughly speaking,
if we think of just
what is the volume
of that spherical
annulus, that would be--
and relative to
the total volume--
that would be r-cube minus
R minus delta cube divided
by r-cube.
So each of the volumes has a
4/3 pi, which I've canceled off.
So this is basically the
volume of the total sphere
minus the volume in
the inner sphere.
So that's just the
volume of the shell.
Then I normalize
it properly here.
So this is one minus delta
over r parentheses cubed.
And if I now--
and I have this expression here.
So now I have at
least an approximation
for what this might look like.
We can also further say
that this approximation here
was valid for the delta
B much less than r.
And when that's the
case, then I also
can say that this
quantity is small.
So at early times that's small.
And I can expand.
All right, this is 1 minus.
And then 1 minus
something cubed,
where that something is
small, is 1 minus 3 times
that something.
That's basically a
tailor expansion.
So that when I work this
out, the ones cancel.
And I get three delta
over R. So what we find
is that this PE, which
we're trying to calculate,
has two limits that
are easy to calculate.
One of them is this 3 delta
over R. And if that's our delta,
then we get 3 square
root of 2 DT times R.
And specifically, the p is
defined up to a certain time
tau v. So I'll now
replace t with tau v
because that is my timescale
for virus deactivation.
And so this would be in the
case where this quantity is--
basically, this ratio here
is much less than one.
And then in the
opposite limit where
this diffusion has completely
spanned the particle
and is getting
much bigger than R,
then this obviously
has to tend to 1.
OK, now, I can write
down a function
that makes this transition
right about when
this thing is of order
one in a variety of ways.
One way we could
do that would be
to write that PE
is approximately
given by 1 minus the exponential
of minus this quantity.
So minus 3 square root of
2 d tau v divided by R.
And you can see there we
have a-- there's sort of--
you could either write
this in terms of a time
where the critical time is--
so we could write this--
just to get more
insight into it,
we could write PE is
approximately 1 minus e
to the minus tau v
over some timescale--
I'll call it tau
d for diffusion--
where we see here that
tau d is R squared over--
and then it's--
To bring inside the square
root, this 3 becomes 9.
And then times 2 is 18.
So 18D.
Now, you may recall from
our last calculation,
the average first passage
time in the sphere calculated
exactly was R squared over 15D.
So this very simple
calculation is clearly
giving us roughly the
right order of magnitude
for that time.
But we're actually
not interested so much
in writing this
in terms of time.
We'd actually like to
write in terms of radius.
So I can also write PE is
1 minus E to the minus R.
I'll call it maybe Rd
for diffusion over R
where Rd is basically all this
stuff, 3 root 2 d tau v. OK,
so this is maybe another
useful way to write that.
And what does this function
look like as a function of R,
this one right here?
So maybe if I sketch
that out, I'll
look at this a little
bit more carefully.
Let's plot this.
So as a function of R, here is
this Rd, this critical size.
When we are smaller than that
critical size, then basically
we have that PE.
The escape probability,
essentially,
is very close to 1, OK,
because then we have--
that's basically just
what we were just arguing.
It's this limit right here.
But then it's a
function that when
it gets much larger
than our d, then it
decays as we suggested
here as sort of 1 over R.
So it's actually a fairly
slow decay in the long run.
So basically, there's
this limit here.
And I just wanted to
get to this picture.
Just to point out that even
though there are obviously
physiological characteristics
having to do with the way
the a virion would actually
get into a host cell
and whether they
would get infected,
but a lot of those
properties should
be independent of the delivery
of the virion in a droplet.
It's really more once the virion
gets out, there's some process.
But what this
calculation shows is
that we would expect a
fairly strong dependence
of the infectivity on
the size of the drop.
Well, in particular, if
we calculate this Rd.
We'll have some
idea that droplets
that are smaller
than that are highly
infectious because every
virion in those droplets
can get out and
infect the host cell.
Whereas if the virus is--
the droplet is much
bigger than that,
then you have this problem where
this dead region in the middle.
And those virions
are not going to be
able to get out in a
reasonable amount of time,
which is set by this tau v.
So for example, a tau v for
SARS COV-2, the coronavirus,
is estimated to be
anywhere from one hour.
There was one study
in aerosol droplets
finding that kind of decay.
But another study found
that after 16 hours,
it was still viable.
So there's not quite a
consensus forming yet.
But it may be a time on the
order of hours, certainly
days, over which the virion
needs to get out of the droplet
in order to be able
to cause infection.
And this calculation shows
you that as a result,
you would expect a size
dependent diffusivity--
or excuse me, a size
dependent infectivity.
And roughly speaking, if
we plug-in the numbers,
these are the aerosol droplets.
And these are the large drops.
We've already done that.
That was our previous
calculation based on this time
here, which is what
I'm calling tau
d here, which
corresponds to this,
is also pretty close
to what we call tau 0.
That was the-- well, that
was the longest escape time,
actually what I call, I
think, tau bar actually,
which was R squared over 15d.
That was the
average escape time.
So basically, we've already
shown that that average escape
time starts to become
days or even months when
we get to large drops.
But for the aerosol
droplets in mucus
anyway, this timescale
is of order minutes
to hours, which is reasonable.
And you would expect those to
be very infectious droplets.